the current schooling system do you  think that's a good model I think the  purpose of education is teachable how to  think rather than how to memorize and  especially now with technology that we  have if you can pass a test with having  an iPhone with you then my opinion the  test was poorly designed the product of  that is people who can add value to  society if that's the system there's a  lot of leeway there in terms of how we  can get there I think the the system  that we have set up is inherited from  the factory worker you know when it was  being designed versus now I think we  need a lot more problem solving skills  than we did back then a lot more Dynamic  thinking processes